a couple of weeks ago we ran a fake
commercial with our good friend Nick
Offerman in which he was making
handcrafted wood emojis we did this as
just kind of a joke and he made these
wooden emojis and here's a clip from the
piece and that's why I'm proud to
introduce my new line of handcrafted
solid wood emojis messages you can build
with my hand-carved wood emojis include
but are not limited to I love you and I
love cats and I love you but I'm sad
that the cat pooped but here's the
strangely and this is absolutely a 10
percent true we started hearing from a
lot of people who said they would buy
giant wooden emojis if somebody offered
a lot of people we heard from a lot of
people they said we want those we
actually want them well good news we
decided to make these big wooden emojis
offer them through team koco.com and
best of all donate all all of the
proceeds to charity
I think that's
to charity
yeah you idiot let my retirement plan I
wanted to retire in the widow all of
that sweet emoji green medicham parole
again not gonna happen sorry Andy just a
little no nothing for you
no it's all going to charity now we
asked our prop master bill toll to start
making them that didn't work out so well
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
son of a [ __ ]
right
that's right that's right there is no
blood in bill tall's body that's we
learned from that sketch anyway we've
teamed up with tilt comm to get these
wooden emojis made here to tell us more
about them is mr. Andy rector you'll get
to choose from any or all of these five
classic emojis carved from solid wood
there's the smiley face the I love you
with heart eyes the wing the cat and of
course the always popular pile of poo I
don't know where any of those would
emerge II seem large heavy and
impractical you bet they are gone and
but that's not all they're also
surprisingly expensive only 100 emojis
will be manufactured and you can own one
for a $100 donation that's right it's
important only 100 are being made but
more important all of the proceeds will
be going to help the Children's Defense
Fund a wonderful charity that works to
ensure a level playing field for all
children now
if you'd like to own one or all of these
wooden emojis and donate to a great
cause
get the details at tilt comm slash team
Coco
Conan couldn't they just write a check
directly to the Children's Defense Fund
sure they could Andy but then they
wouldn't get one of these limited
edition handcrafted emojis good point
smiley face thanks a lot [ __ ]
you
you